[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday november 18th
i'm cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor and your host this week
on the show today is putin making a move
on ukraine while europe and america are
distracted by migrants on a polish
belarusian border
that's what our political editor james
forsyth argues in this week's cover
piece he's joining the show together
with spectator contributor owen matthews
who warns against seeing a putin master
plan in every corner
meanwhile in westminster the tory's
sleeve scandal goes into its third week
as the prime minister tries to win back
his party while trying to push through
an unpopular u-turn on hs2 our deputy
political editor katie balls and our
assistant editor isabel hardman joins me
to discuss we'll also be taking a look
at new evidence about covert's origins
the most genetically similar virus to
sars cov2 has been found in laos what
does this now mean for the lab league
theory i'll be speaking to matt ridley
and the biologist michael warriby
plus is megan's mask finally slipping
our deputy editor freddie gray will be
joining the show to discuss the rather
unsurprising revelations that meghan
markle has been briefing the media and
finally rod little joins the show we
talk about durham university's safe
guidelines for students doing sex work
and he defends the importance of stigma
before we get going if you enjoy
spectator tv you should subscribe to our
youtube channel just click the red
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too
you can get 12 weeks off the magazine
and a free 20 pound amazon voucher for
just 12 pounds to take up on the deal
just go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer
first there are many images of migrants
on the border between poland and belarus
in recent weeks but what's less covered
is putin's ramp up of russian military
forces on the ukrainian border
is moscow about to slip another crimea
annexation under the radar helped by the
distraction caused by russian ally
belarus
in his cover piece this week james
forsyth argues that the west must be
alive to putin's plots he joins the show
now together with spectator contributor
owen matthews who also writes in the
magazine this week
james to start with tell us about the
test that you argue putin is putting the
west under
so i think what you can see at the
moment is uh in uh ukraine where the
russians are massing forces on the
border the western balkans and belarus
can have three challenges to the west
now
i don't mean that putin uh i don't mean
lukashenko in belarus is a simple putin
puppet i think the best description i've
heard of him is that he is kind of
putin's problem child
but the russians haven't chosen to
de-escalate the situation that you know
you had russian paratroopers landing on
the belarusian side of the border you've
had uh russian military aircraft flying
around and i think that i think the
issue here is is this is you you're in a
situation where uh
russia feels emboldened by uh the surge
in the gas price uh
you know the russian energy weapon is
more potent at this point than it has
been uh for some time
and i also think that putin is probing i
think putin is probing to see how
serious the us is about this shift to
china
and what that means for europe um how
much the americans are going to leave
the europeans to it when it comes to
defence
and i think that is why um anthony blink
in the u.s extra state made this
extraordinary warning a week ago when he
said when he said in a press conference
of the ukrainian foreign minister look
you know we think that the russians
might be considering in invading eastern
ukraine in the same way that they annex
crimea in 2014.
and james what's putin's ultimate goal
here just to see how far he can get in
ukraine without meeting resistance
i think putin is a tactical opportunist
i also think that putin would like
russia to once more have a near abroad
um in which it is dominant and i think
the challenge for that is that the west
is very reluctant to to grant him that
now owen on these three flash points
that james is talking about how much
control does putin have over this james
mentioned the word de-escalate does he
have much control in de-escalating the
situation in belarus for example
uh well i think james is absolutely on
the money um that in fact um lukaszenko
is not putin's proxy he's a problem
child he's perfectly capable of his own
crazy stunts um
forcing the ryanair airliner to
uh to land in belarusian territory so he
could arrest a dissident i mean
lukashenko is is is out of control but
on the other hand he's also
putin's sort of more or less only
regional ally
james is also totally right that um
putin would like a near abroad and
actually uh there's strong evidence that
ukraine is absolutely obsessing putin
he's been writing in his own historical
screens he's been talking about
ukrainian speeches
the loss of ukraine um
as a strategic ally and partner is a
major failure for putin
the question of how much he's in control
of lukashenko i think not very much how
much he's in control of his own troops
well obviously very much and um the
build-up on the ukrainian border is a
signal um he's certainly also testing uh
washington and he's sending a strong
message
that
vladimir zillianski's overtures to
washington um
the trip that he made in september
where he talked about ukraine joining
nato that's absolute anathema um the
biggest question is is he actually going
to invade ukraine
in that sense i think
clearly there's
um going to be a massive
um
it's a massive strategic
diplomatic and military problem for him
to invade
non-russian speaking ukraine he's
already chipped off
the bits of ukraine that could
conceivably
kind of
be
at some point part of the russian empire
um
crimea russian-speaking massive majority
for joining russia they seem to be quite
content for being part of russia eastern
ukraine kind of less so actually i mean
the two provinces
lugansk and danielsk which are now under
rebel control um actually they um
you you could make a case
for them to join russia but again more
difficult the rest of ukraine really
know
and ironically 2014 did one thing for
the ukrainian state and that was
actually unite them behind for a sense
of ukrainian nationhood which they had
never really had in their history
so in that sense actually
whether putin's actually going to
truly invade a country that hates russia
and will resist strongly and will pull
in
um
western allies in one somewhat in one
form or another whether that actually
is
what macron
described when he said he would defend
the territorial integrity of ukraine
does that mean that macron's actually
gonna
go to war with russia that kind of
remains to be seen but uh testing the
west certainly that's putin's intention
he say intends to send a very clear
signal um that he's
very serious about
ukraine never joining nato despite the
fact that that's also by the way what
joe biden told vladimir zirianski is
you're not going to join nato uh but
nonetheless putin putin is very very
adamant about stopping any kind of talk
of ukraine moving westwards well let's
talk about ukraine in a bit more detail
in just a second owen and james but for
now owen would you say that what's
happening in belarus um is actually
quite inconvenient for putin and his
efforts
massively massively and actually as
james rightly points out uh the news
this week yesterday that um that um the
german regulators refused or at least
delayed the approval of nordstream 2 in
gazprom's pipeline
is a massive setback for putin and
clearly it's linked to putin's uh to
lukashenko's actions clearly it's linked
to putin's inability to fulfill or
unwillingness to fulfill angela merkel's
personal request to putin to solve that
crisis and this is the german response
that's the last thing that
putin needs what he needs is european
money he wants to take as
much advantage as possible of high
european gas prices he wants to lock in
more consumers in europe um ideally what
he'd like is more european allies people
rather you know like victor orban i mean
he has been you know very keen
historically um to sort of chip off
to divide and conquer and make as many
friends as possible among european
malcontents as possible
lukashenko's actions go directly against
that strategy he needs
that border crisis like he needs a hole
in the head however he can't be seen to
go against his ally really
and
there's not really any way
that he can um
that he can back down from this
having initially
made some symbolic gesture politics to
support um support lukashenko um and um
so yes indeed i mean the the belarusian
crisis actually is
not something that putin really wants
and i personally don't believe that it's
not something it's something that putin
kind of
inspired or ordered
james in your cover piece you talk about
how anthony blinken from the u.s side
sees all this do you think that there is
this tendency on the american side to
misunderstand russian motivations and
this you know this idea that russia is
out to get friends as many friends
possible in europe maybe through a
salami slicing uh european union
no no i think that if you look at what
blinking said he's quite clear but that
they don't know what russia wants i mean
the worry is that what you saw uh is
that
as i was saying that in eastern ukraine
there are russian proxies essentially in
control of territory there is there is
an informal line of control and i think
the worry isn't about um you know russia
trying to invade the whole of ukraine
but russia trying to formalize that
presence in eastern ukraine and and pull
those parts of eastern ukraine into
russia i think that is what worries uh
the west i think the west is also
worried that um it has less of a read on
uh vladimir putin than what he is
planning
uh that you know that there's there is
uh there is far less uh western
intelligence assets in russia uh than
there once were and and it is becoming
harder to read i mean that's one of the
things that is causing concerns in
european capitals i also think that um
the us is is traumatized by what
happened in 2014 and it's worth
remembering that joe biden was vice
president in the obama white house you
had the kind of map of europe changed by
force essentially and all the west could
do was to impose sanctions after the
fact so i think there is a desire to
avoid a repeat of that and i think
blinken was deliberately rattling the
cage to say to european countries that
have a second you've got to be alert for
this and what might happen
now owen um in james's piece he also
mentions america's wider foreign policy
goal under biden which is to tilt
towards the indo-pacific towards china
how does moscow see that tillage does it
see
america distracted and an opportunity to
slip in and get what it wants in the
meantime
well that's true although i would say
just to james's last point i mean there
was actually like a technicality in so
far as the current build-up of a hundred
thousand troops is actually nowhere near
east ukraine it's not near donbass it's
actually the other end of ukraine it's
actually the most ukrainian the most
nationalist the most sort of
anti-russian part of ukraine it's
actually towards the belarussian border
so so technically speaking um just you
know that the build-up is not directly
connected to an invasion or an assertion
of of of power in eastern ukraine yet
but um but the point stands indeed i
mean that that if he was going to invade
part of ukraine that was that would be
the sensible part to invade to invade
and strengthen his his his grip on those
rebel provinces but um i think the the
the the in terms of america's pivot to
china um putin doesn't like it because
um i think he craves attention he
he wants to be seen as you know a major
world player and the last time he
pulled a very similar stunt um right at
the beginning of the biden
administration back in april and may he
did exactly the same thing he just
mobilized his troops
and
it was widely seen as a as a rejection
of the biden uh white house's pivot
towards china he he he
it's very important part of putin's
self-image and his public image and his
domestic support is that he is fighting
russia's corner and he's a world leader
with with whom the world reckons and
that was why i mean
there was there was talk of him not
meeting biden in geneva he definitely
got his face time uh with the help of
100 000 troops on the border that's the
way putin rolls um and on a wider sense
of course in a wider sense of course
biden is completely right um china is an
economic superpower it's enormously
important for america
both strategically and economically
russia is not it's not an economic
superpower by any means it's actually
has a gdp smaller than mexico where
actually that will uh maybe change with
the with with the higher with the higher
oil prices this year maybe climb up you
know past south korea maybe i mean that
they may even hit here the top 10 of
world economies but actually you know
economically
russia is is insignificant strategically
it's really also pretty insignificant
bigger except for its nuclear deterrent
of course um uh it's
the only way it really can stay at the
top table is just buying by being a
world-class equal opportunities
disruptor
and uh you know that and
that's uh precisely what uh what what
putin is is emphasizing is that actually
he
he's uh um john mccain
famously described russia as a gas
station posing as a country um and cyrus
france described it as upper volta with
rockets i mean nothing really has
changed i mean it really it really is
but vaulted with rockets except that it
has that
fatal capacity to
mess up its neighbors if it wants to
and um
ironically sanctions actually have
proved have have actually
proved
completely ineffective in controlling
putin's behavior i mean already you know
the russia and russian companies have
been cut off
uh from
international financial markets
effectively um
and that hasn't changed putin's behavior
at all putin himself
banned imports of agricultural products
from the eu that was his that was
putin's return sanction russia is a
russia's economy is basically sort of
decoupled from
[Music]
from europe and from the rest of the
world except for one key thing which is
energy
except that oops you have cop 22. it's a
good cop 26 and suddenly
decarbonization means phasing out coal
means buying russian gas and putin knows
that perfectly well so the only sanction
that would really bite i mean there's a
few sort of technical things they could
cut off the russian banking system from
visa or mastercard or from the swift
system i mean there there are certain
things that that
that the west could do on the sort of
banking and financial side but the only
thing that really that putin and russia
really care about is not getting
european euros for russia's gas and
that's obviously never going to happen
because
gas prices and the infrastructure is
there gas prices are high and
the the europeans will just freeze
without russian gas and putin knows it
so in the uh so
as
james said right at the beginning and
putin is emboldened by that and uh in
terms of sanctions there's nothing
really that uh europe can can can do
on that front
so
putin actually just really wants
uh
the west to stay out of
his backyard and not
woo
ukraine but it's a completely vicious
cycle is the the more he saber rattles
um in reaction to west's overtures to
ukraine or rather that ukraine's
overtures to the west the more those
overtures the
become urgent and intense the more
military aid
the washington gives
to kiev which is now one of the biggest
recipients of western military aid in
the world
and um and the more paranoid putin gets
so it's it's complete vicious vicious
circle
thanks james and owen
now coming back to westminster the
government is set to u-turn on
long-standing hs2 plans in a move that's
unlikely to cheer up his colleagues in
the conservative party
after all we are going into the third
week of talking about tory's sleeves yet
the stories are simply not going away
how strong is the conservative party
unity at the moment
joining me to discuss is katie balls and
isabel hartman
it's about to start with let's talk
about this hs2 uter what's happening
there so today is the integrated rail
review which transport secretary grant
shaps has unveiled in the commons and it
confirms the fears of a lot of people
across the political spectrum including
conservative mps that the government is
not going ahead with a number of
improvements to certain lines
particularly in the north of england so
the eastern leg of high-speed rail 2 is
being scrapped and also what has become
known as northern powerhouse rail which
was improvements to the trans-pennine
route
are also being dropped and this was
something that came up at prime
minister's questions this week with jake
berry who is the
leader of the northern research group of
conservative mps asking the prime
minister whether voters in the north had
been right to take him at his word mr
speaker in july 2019 i was in manchester
when the prime minister committed to
build a new line northern powerhouse
rail between manchester and leeds it was
a third commitment reaffirmed in our
manifesto in november 2019
and last month reaffirmed in the prime
minister's conference speech in
manchester were the voters of the north
right to take the prime minister at his
word and uh you should have seen the
foul look that the prime minister threw
to jake berry asking this question at
pmq's
he insisted that they were right
but today's integrative rail review
suggests otherwise
yeah that's interesting as well because
jake barry is a former ally of the prime
minister katie is all of this um how has
it gone down inside the party as i
mentioned in my introduction boris
johnson is not in the party's best books
at the moment anyway and after all it is
a manifesto pledge
yeah so i mean i don't think it's been
celebrated there's clearly lots of
people who are quite worried about this
and i don't think anyone's really saying
this is a win i think in terms of where
the cracks are in support for this
obviously it very much depends on
what area you represent there are some
winners and losers from this so there
are some areas that will still get
improvements you know journey times
being slashed and they're quite keen to
say this will happen quicker
than hs2 would have done so you're going
to see impact sooner but there are
clearly some areas that are not going to
have that and i think particularly um
those around leads are quite worried
about this
i think in terms of where this fits into
the general unhappiness of boris johnson
at the moment
i think that clearly after a damaging
few weeks on tory's sleeves and was not
on a particularly forgiving mood and
we're seeing that at the 1922 committee
last night where um
boris johnson addressed mps for the
first time really since the patterson
route kicked off and while there weren't
that many questions directly about the
patterson handling you can almost see
the impact where mps who are usually
quite loyal are more willing to ask
difficult questions about other things
the government has said they're going to
do where they're really going to deliver
this where the proof is and i think um
with this announcement today it's just
adding to that fear that the government
is not on top of things we're going to
deliver the things that many mps thought
it would where then boris johnson first
one that majority
and as well let's talk about the sleaze
story that's still rumbling on you were
watching the prime minister at prime
minister's questions and at the liaison
committee on wednesday
what did you think of his performance i
mean is he going to be able to shut down
the story anytime soon
he didn't have a good day yesterday he
had a really poor performance at prime
minister's questions he was quite
visibly rattled then
at the liaison committee
he still i think believes that he can
just
get away
with this scandal and one of the
problems is that the way in which he's
handled it over the past
over a fortnight
now has left his party split so that
whatever he does from now on he will end
up angering one side of the party or
another and that's a very difficult
place to be in particularly as you're
going into
a difficult winter with a lot of
concerns about inflation
nhs waiting times and ambulance waiting
times are
growing in salience for voters and
obviously worries about
shortages as well as we come up to
christmas to have your party uh not
united behind you but actually having a
fight with itself and and against you
is a very difficult position for the
prime minister to be in he thought
yesterday when he was questioned on this
matter by kier starmer at prime
minister's questions that making jokes
about uh the offer of work that the
leader of the opposition received when
he was in jeremy corbyn's shadow cabinet
from mishkondaraya he had this pun of uh
the honorable gentleman has committed
mish conduct
uh which elicited groans from everyone
listening uh he thought that that was a
good way to deflect it but
it's not particularly inspiring when
you've got a prime minister saying
basically you know in effect well yes
okay we're bad but you guys are bad too
um
you know there's a sort of there's a
high ground that you want a prime
minister to take and that's certainly
not where boris johnson has ended up
it's interesting what isabel says there
about the michigan de reia comment
because the prime minister does seem to
be very fixated on this story which is
uh something kistama denies that jeremy
corbyn stepped in to stop um kirsten
taking this as a second job and when he
addressed um mps uh the new intake of
mps the 29 lead 2019ers um on monday
night oh drinks reception he referred to
kirsten as unremembered for his
constituency but then added on and
mishkan did rare so you can see him
really wanting to hammer this point but
i agree with isabel in a sense it just
seems quite an odd way to attack
particularly given that isn't the work
kirsten even did in the end
israel do you think this is going to
have lasting damage to boris johnson's
relationship with this party in
particular this fracturing that you're
talking about i mean that will the red
wall mps for example realize that this
prime minister is actually just a little
bit gaff-prone
he does have a very transactional
relationship with his party and always
has done that the reason they picked him
is is because he's a winner rather than
they particularly like him or indeed
particularly like his his brand of
conservatism which is why you've seen
a lot of disquiet over the levels of
public spending uh and uh resulting
taxation over the past few months from
uh conservative back bench
mps i think it would be easier to see a
heel in the rifts
if the autumn and winter looked as
though things were going to improve i
mean quite often politicians look
forward to christmas there's a nice
positive break from things but at the
moment it's not clear whether people are
going to get a normal christmas having
had a very abnormal christmas last year
so that's one of the uh one of the
problems in in the medium term for him
but in in terms of the the next election
uh it's not yet clear how much this is
going to stick it has certainly damaged
the conservatives standing in the polls
but has almost taken them to a more
normal position for a party uh in its
mid-term between elections
rather than
something that they might particularly
worry about as they're heading for a
general election i think the thing that
they are still taking comfort from
is that labor is only good when the
conservatives are doing badly and that
it isn't particularly good at
articulating why people should vote for
it as a party uh more that is good as
kirsten was this week at criticizing the
conservatives
well katie finally let's talk a little
bit more about laban in particular
angela rainer who is the subject of your
political column in this week's
spectator um tell us about angela arena
because she does seem to be the only
spotless politician on on the leadership
um on either side in this row yeah i
mean it goes back to boris johnson's
fascination michigan derea as a law firm
in the sense that we've seen obviously
lots of damage to the tory party
um in terms of boris johnson's standing
in terms of tory mps who are very
unhappy they now and having to think
again about second jobs consultancy work
um but also
opposition politicians have found it
tricky ed davey
and seventy eight thousand pounds a year
in consultancy work and therefore you
haven't really seen the liberal
democrats play too big a role in this
debate and i think that kierstarma
because he has had paid legal work david
lammy a member of his shadow cabinet
when these politicians go out to attack
it doesn't take long in an interview for
it to suddenly turn into well hang on a
minute you took this money i think where
angela rayne has really come into her
own is she is in many ways spotless on
this she left school age 16 pregnant she
went on to work as a care worker and
then for her union and as a result if
you look at the um mp salary of 82 000
pounds that to her is probably the
highest she's ever earned and it's not
seen in the way that some npc is almost
a hardship that you have to top up other
money because it's just such a difficult
amount to live on and i think that that
shines a lot of public opinion there's
lots of people who will not earn more
than 80k who i think look on to this
debate in westminster and find it almost
feels quite detached from reality
and i think that
therefore you often see angela reyna on
the attack for labour and she's been
doing you know lots of the media and
even introducing kids stammer when he's
been going for it and i think that
given angela was getting a lot of
criticism a few weeks ago after labour
conference where she suggested tories
with scum and late night comments she's
now apologised for that
blatantly but has apologized and i do
think there's a sense again that this is
uh you know one to watch
katie and isabel thanks very much for
joining spectator tv
next well we'll probably never know for
sure whether covet came from a lab or a
natural spillover every new shred of
evidence is worth examining in this
week's episode we'll be talking to matt
ridley about the new coronavirus variant
found in laos which is the closest
relative to sars cov2 that has been
discovered yet it has excited those in
favor of a natural spillover theory matt
however argues that evidence is not so
simple in a piece for the spectator this
week
welcome to spectator tv matt um to start
with tell us about this new variant and
how has it been interpreted
yeah well we've known for some time that
uh similar viruses are found in
southeast asia a couple from cambodia
from thailand and elsewhere but these
ones found in
2020 in laos include one virus that is
ever so slightly the most closely
related virus to uh sarsko v2
and it was collected in live sometime in
2020 by uh french and
laotian scientists it's not the ancestor
it's not the progenitor of the virus
because it's too dissimilar it's 96.8
percent the same but that's not 99.7
percent um so you know here's a possible
source for the virus outside china
because until now the closest relative
of sarsko v2 was one from a mine shaft
collected in 2012 by wuhan scientists
in
southern yunnan 1800 miles by 1800
kilometers by road from uh wuhan so
this
one appears to be
uh from outside the country so maybe
somehow the virus got from laos to wuhan
the central question we've got to ask
ourselves is how did a bat virus found
in southern china or in southeast asia
get to wuhan a city where the bats don't
carry these viruses and where people
haven't been picking them up yeah and
you have some idea for how that
transportation happened can you tell us
about that
well
so i thought yes okay well maybe this
does uh suggest that scientists weren't
involved in that transfer but then
some documents were obtained by freedom
of information just a couple of weeks
ago which showed that the eco health
alliance which is this american
foundation that works very closely with
the wuhan institute of virology using
american money to search for bat viruses
in caves in southern china was also
involved in sampling in laos among other
countries
and here's the key point when they
found viruses
they sent them not to a local laboratory
not to an american laboratory but to one
of their partners laboratories the wuhan
institute of virology and they had
scientists from the wuhan institute of
virology with them in laos when they
were collecting viruses so it's not at
all impossible that either a wuhan
scientist got infected in laos and went
back to wuhan or a sample was found in
laos and was sent to wuhan either way
the only known link we have between
where these closely related viruses are
found
and wuhan
at the moment is scientists we don't
have any evidence none at all for
wildlife traders or
hunters or anybody else getting in close
contact with
virus with bats and their viruses and
then going straight to wuhan
now for those proponents um of a natural
spillover theory and they look at this
laos variant and they think look
something so similar happens in nature
have they responded to this freedom of
information um you know treasure trove
of information that's come out
about how it was exactly transported to
rohan do they have a response to that
well at the moment the the response is
that um there is a wildlife trade
um
wildlife is exported from countries like
laos uh to china
and some of it ends up in markets the
vast majority of it ends up in guangdong
province in southern china because
that's where this kind of food is is
much preferred it's it's there's a very
small trade to cities as far north as
wuhan
and so yes it's possible that a wildlife
trader has brought an animal from
southern china to wuhan and that it's
somewhere along the line he came into
contact with a bat we know that bats
were not on sale in the market in wuhan
so it's not it's not a bat that's that's
being marketed for food it's some other
animal that's come into contact with a
bat now it's quite possible that other
animal is a human being that's really
the point we need to take seriously yes
well it's interesting you make that
point about guangdong province matt i'm
from more north in china and we used to
always kind of sneer at those from
guangdong province in the south of china
for eating all this kind of unsavory
stuff there's a they've got a reputation
within china as well um right phoenix
dragon soup which was where the the
civic cats were used and things like
that yeah yeah which was involved in
sars the first stars matt just finally
what do you think about the lab league
theory now because you finish your
article by writing that the astonishing
truth remains this the outbreak
happening a city with the world's
largest research program on bat-born
coronaviruses whose scientists had gone
to at least two places where these sars
kovi ii like viruses live and brought
them back to rohan and to nowhere else i
mean you sound pretty convinced that it
does come from a lab
no i'm not convinced my co-author alina
chan and i on our book called viral
we started out thinking it was almost
certainly a natural event but we thought
it was very important to find out but
the evidence began to accumulate that it
was not a natural event absolutely no
evidence for an infected animal in a
market
zero evidence that the early cases were
you know particular food handlers or
anything like that
and at the same time the evidence began
to get stronger that the research
program that had been going on in the
wuhan institute of virology did involve
very similar viruses and did involve a
great deal of concealment of data
including taking offline a key database
that means that we need to take this
possibility seriously that's still where
we are let's find out what it was both
of us
the authors of this book lean towards a
lab leak theory now but we're not saying
we know we're just saying please can we
find out please can we investigate
properly it's very important that we do
that
matt thanks for joining spectator tv
so what about the alternative professor
michael warreby head of ecology and
evolutionary biology at the university
of arizona wrote in the science journal
back in may that the origins of covet
need to be investigated in september
though warriby and his colleagues found
evidence to suggest that covert jump
from animals to humans twice making it
less likely that it originated from a
lab
michael joins the show
michael to start with how do you
interpret the discovery of the new
coronavirus variant in laos
uh yeah there's
there's multiple uh
variants of the virus that have been
recovered from
natural populations of bats and laos
uh and one of them is now the closest
overall to sarsko v2 a little closer
than
this virus that was taken out of a mine
shaft in yunnan province in southern
china
but more interestingly in the in the
really important region of the spike
protein on the outside of the virus that
is kind of like
velcro for the human receptor its velcro
is such a great match for the human
receptor um
that it it looks as good as
sarsko v2 in terms of its potential for
binding to human cells
and that's interesting because
a lot of the speculation about
a
so-called lab leak origin of sars cov2
began with this idea that oh my goodness
this virus is so well adapted to binding
human cells that it it must have been
manipulated in the lab to uh to be so uh
that it couldn't possibly have existed
in nature well the laos uh bat samples
show us that yes it does exist in nature
uh and they also have a motif
uh
that is similar to what's called the
fear and cleavage site and without going
into nauseating detail
the fear and cleavage site is a little
stretch of amino acids that's kind of
like the secret sauce uh of sars-ko v2
which allows it to really successfully
invade our cells and and
infect new hosts
it's not something that's been seen in
other very closely related viruses and
bats but these these viruses from
laos are only one amino acid away from
having what we call a functional
furan cleavage site so there again a
sort of
signature uh of uh of a natural origin
of the key features of uh sarsko v2 but
i guess people who think that leaked
from a lab could still say this virus
could still have been studied it could
still have been in wuhan for example um
and so just because it occurs naturally
doesn't mean it wasn't coming this
particular pandemic didn't come from an
accidental lab lab leak yeah fair point
and and this has been an interesting
question and it's been something that
interested me from from the start is
um
why did this pandemic start
in wuhan which does have a lab that
studies these sorts of bat viruses it's
a question worth addressing and not just
sweeping under the carpet and i've been
quite prominent in
for example
um
signing this letter to science magazine
that prompted biden's 90-day
intelligence review saying you know
let's take this seriously let's look at
the evidence
um
and in fact that letter was
was my idea
uh at the same time even at that point
that i proposed that idea uh the
evidence clearly pointed much more
persuasively to a natural origin of the
virus and so on the one hand if you're
if you're looking under the microscope
at two times magnification yeah it's
interesting that this thing starts in
wuhan although wuhan is like new york
city it's a huge place
uh
well connected to the rest of china it's
a transport hub so it's not actually
that surprising and in fact my own
research has shown that if if a pandemic
is going to start it's actually going to
start in an area like wuhan where you
have so many people packed together
that the virus actually if it has a
chance to start transmitting will
successfully gain a foothold whereas if
it jumps in a rural area most likely you
know 99 of the time the same sars cov2
virus is going to go extinct okay so two
times
magnification interesting that it it
starts in wuhan now go up to 10 or 50
times magnification and look within
wuhan and this is what my recent or my
upcoming
paper that's going to come out on
thursday in science magazine does is is
it looks more closely and when you look
more closely
there's no relationship to the early
cases geographically to the wuhan
institute of virology
for example
they cluster around one of the few sites
in the city
that sold animals like raccoon dogs
which brought us the first sars
so of all the places in the city uh uh
concert halls bars um uh
gatherings of
of large numbers of people office towers
etc etc much more likely sources of an
early uh spread of the virus
it's like a
a home depot uh
sized that's a bit of an american
geographical illusion but you know it's
120 meters by 80 meters it's a tiny
little building uh
uh and there's only four sites in in the
city that have that pattern
and so
th
and and you know half of the cases
early on are linked to that one site you
have to be
really really
tied to a lab leak origin to not look at
that evidence and say hey there's
something here you know
one other thing if if you don't mind me
adding to that uh
issue of okay this letter starts this
uh intelligence review into motion uh
one of the things that i show in my
paper uh is that
i think one of the key
factoids that was uh influential in the
intelligence community's review
and probably swung the fbi
to their
kind of surprising position of thinking
that there was moderate evidence in
terms of the lab leak was this idea that
the very earliest case was someone who
was not linked to juan on market
and indeed lived close to
one of the wuhan institute of virology
facilities in southern wuhan
well my paper shows
that
that
individual actually was not the earliest
case that there was a mistake in in the
time of onset
which was given as december 8th on
december 8th he actually had a dental
infection
and it wasn't until december 16th that
he had fever and symptoms
related to covet
well december 11th we know there was
already at least one vendor at juan on
market
who was infected so i i do think with
with this kind of
new perspective
uh that in the intelligence community
for a start will be reassessing their
evaluations
and i would hope uh that lab leak
proponents would also reassess their
evaluations but i think evidence has
shown that
um
that the people who want to
advocate for a particular theory
um have trouble taking on
uh evidence that contradicts that theory
so it will be interesting to see
what the reaction is to to my paper
michael warriby thank you for joining
spectator tv
next the queen canceled her appearance
at the cenotaph last weekend because of
a sprained back
fueling conversations about succession
but are the new generation of royals
ready to step up
in this week's magazine freddie gray
takes a look at the grandkids and writes
about the war between the fab form
william kate harry and megan
to explain freddie joins the show
now freddie tell us about the modern
monarchy because you write that it needs
some drama to keep people's attention
but this time they may have gone too far
what's the latest
well i think the danger uh for the
monarchy particularly with the young
royals
and i've been boring on about this for a
few years now is that they are turning
into a kind of reality tv show whereas
monarchy i think
can just about
work in a in a very fiercely democratic
age
uh when it does it has a little bit of
soap opera
uh but it's still essentially this old
institution that goes around doing quite
boring things like cutting ribbons
uh the trouble for the younger royals or
the trouble for the monarchy with the
younger royals is that uh the row
between harry and and megan and
catherine and william is turning into a
sort of nasty soap opera
actually a reality tv show a sort of
slightly ghastly reality tv show and i'm
not sure that um
you know once the queen goes
uh nobody likes talking about it but
she's very old
uh i'm not sure that the monarchy is
going to be able to thrive
uh as a kind of keeping up with the
kardashian style
uh
reality show
yeah well especially with the latest
blunder from meghan markle whose court
case against the mail on sunday is
bringing up all these ways in which
she's been briefing the media through
her form of press aid jason nauf who
seems to be pretty happy to um backstab
his former employer you know saying
stuff about how she told him to brief
her biographers on finding freedom
about how she wrote the letter to her
father with it potentially being leaked
in mind and writing things like daddy so
that in an unfortunate event that it
leaked she could pull on the
heartstrings with her words i mean all
of this is coming up because of a former
staffer yeah i think
megan's problem i think and it's
actually something prince charles has
had a problem with is that people who
work
for her uh seem to dislike her a lot uh
and as a result uh they they eventually
turn on her and i think she's going to
emerge increasingly as this sort of hate
figure
and she's probably not that bad but she
definitely seems to upset people
yeah very much so what about charles
then i mean i wouldn't probably watch a
reality show where he's the main
character he doesn't strike me as the
most interesting person is he going to
be the savior to a kind of more boring
monarchy well possibly except charles
has always
liked to pontificate that's always been
his problem he likes to pontificate
about
climate change uh shakespeare
uh various things he's always thought
that he had genuinely interesting things
to say and he's wanted to say them and
the queen's great uh talent and great
achievement really was just not to say
anything at all and that's what people
want from a monarchy really essentially
i mean obviously we want the soap opera
and we want the drama but what people
really need from the monarchy is the
sense that they're above politics or
above the culture wars if you like um
charles i think has learned this
but uh have the younger roles it looks
like they haven't
yeah
yeah and what about prince andrew then
because stateside that's still ongoing
in a civil lawsuit with virginia joffrey
um is the queen opening herself up for
criticism by hiring these expensive
lawyers for andrew if this case blows up
even more
well i don't know i mean we don't really
know anything about the andrew kidd i
mean we know that everyone knows the
allegations nobody knows if they're true
uh obviously he's not very good at doing
his own pr
as we saw
last year and um i think the queen's
probably doing the right thing in in uh
trying to support her son
but uh yes it's an embarrassing story
and it's another example and this has
been the same story since the 80s when i
grew up
of the royals when they kind of dabble
in
party land and celebrity culture and all
this stuff it always goes wrong
and you know the queen has to try and
tidy up the mess
thanks freddie
finally in his column this week rod lidl
writes in defense of stigma arguing that
it can be a good indeed vital thing
durham university student union recently
announced that it was starting safety
courses for student sex workers to break
down the stigma surrounding the
profession
shouldn't we be focused on encouraging
people not to do it in the first place
rod asks
well to discuss rod joins me now
now rod when i was in university i
didn't find the career service or the
student union all that inspiring or
helpful but you're writing your column
this week about this extraordinary
service being provided by durham's
student union tell us about it
yeah i think i think it sprung from
leicester university though i may have
got that wrong
but it's doing the rounds of some of the
universities and basically it's offering
uh
students a couple of courses
um on
how to
uh safely uh involve themselves in
prostitution
but
you know it's just it's just one of
those stories
from the front line of the culture war
which sort of explodes like how it's
earned
you see it and you can't resist it uh
and their argument is that uh
uh that that that some students because
they're skint uh resort to uh stuff like
having sugar daddies or
or uh or or indeed prostitution um and
that they ought to be able to do it
safely so that's putting it the side
that the university uh puts it or the
students union puts it um
they also say as they always will say
that their aim is to destigmatize
uh
sex workers
and that's that's really what the column
is about the notion
that it would be a good idea to
destigmatize prostitution well rod i
think we do have to say sex work now as
the uh the sanitized way of saying that
um do you think it's working it's it's a
ludicrous title
that whoring is a better title uh but of
course you can't get away with that
anymore but but you see the way in which
the grammar is policed
moves you to a position where you are
beginning to destigmatize something
which really really shouldn't be
destigmatized because it's dangerous
it's immoral it's filthy it's dangerous
again and it's
exploitative and sexist you know
i don't know how much more bad it could
be you know you need to distinguish you
need to destigmatize that no you need a
stigma for it i guess it's like taking
it to the extremist notion that some
modern feminists have that you know
women are in control of their bodies if
they want to be sexy if they want to
wear skimpy clothes that's their choice
and therefore if they want to sell their
body that's also their choice um i guess
you're not a body positive feminist then
rod
well there are some feminists well i
think feminism is
and has historically been split on this
and and i guess i come from
that wave of feminism which was around
in the 70s
um
which i think was more potent than the
kind of revisionist feminism we have now
um so i'm kind of down with the turfs
most of whom were part of that seventies
uh they're shalimah firestone and uh
people like that wonderful writers very
acerbic writers um
uh
and most of them most of the family
signing then would have been as
grotesquely appalled by prostitution as
you know i am today
um and i would have thought you were
cindy you know it's
it's uh it's exploitative it's
objectifying women it's also filthy and
immoral you know
that's how it seems to me now if you
want to destigmatize it um i i don't
quite see how you can do that because
it's transactional it's unpleasant the
only argument i've heard from feminists
more recently which which
supports
prostitution is that
effectively marriage is prostitution
you know so i i have heard that before
now well only if you get money out of
your marriage well
the old traditional idea of marriage
being that the woman
became effectively the husband's chattel
which is the old you know uh 19th
century view of the uh of the
of marriage which was created of course
the the modern marriage was created
largely at the time of the industrial
revolution um and you know the manor and
the money the woman was there to breed
and look after the house and and so i
can i could kind of see
where feminism would come from in in
arguing the toss over that but but but
but i don't think you then go full blast
and say but that means prostitution
should
should be allowed because you know it's
uh two wrongs don't make a right yeah
rod i guess what i do think is that if
people are going to be doing this kind
of work and you know in some ways it's
the oldest profession isn't it then i
kind of want young people to be doing it
in a safe way or all people to be doing
it in safeway if it's going to happen at
all then why not make it safer do you
think that's a ludicrous position no no
because it legitimizes it because saying
this is how to do it legitimizes an
appalling
an appalling thing i mean
students also shoplift
should they be given advice on how to
shoplift properly and how to do so in
comparative safety and avoid the
security guard i mean it no you you
don't do things like that because you
have to keep some sort of moral standard
and it is about moral standards and
nobody needs moral standards more than
you know the generation which are now in
university we all did and i did
and rode your column moves on more
widely as you say to other types of
things that should be stigmatized can
you tell us about your argument there
well the argument is is is true
especially that
that there's been a howl around for the
last 30 to 40 years about various things
we need to to destigmatize
and in almost every case the
destigmatizing of those things has made
society worse and made the outcomes for
individuals worse
the thing about stigma is that it's not
something from the government you know
it's not something which comes from
academia it's something which is kind of
from the people
and it's not arbitrary it's based upon
logic and common sense even if it is
imbued with christian morality
and it's it's it's a means of society
suggesting to people that the things
they're doing
won't work out very well for them and
are anti-social and if you look at the
things we've destigmatized
the most obvious and first one is
divorce
um and the consequence of d
back in the sixties you know a divorcee
was looked upon as being someone rather
shady and seeding uh that's all gone
completely i mean i'm divorced i mean
most people are now divorced um
uh marriages simply don't last anymore
but it hasn't been to our benefit it
hasn't been either to the benefit of the
people who've got divorced and by that i
mean particularly the poorest of us for
the poorest of us divorce is
catastrophic financially and it
certainly hasn't been beneficial for the
children uh and we know from
a multitude of of uh of
social studies that children from
divorced parents end up doing worse at
school have worse employment prospects
and more likely to get into trouble with
the law than those who are with parents
who are married
you know who stayed together so so that
didn't work
we've also de-stigmatized and this makes
me sound awfully like mary whitehouse i
know
uh cohabitation and again i've cohabited
you know i was part of that generation
which which bought all this stuff
but again
cohabiting and then having children
means that those children are more
likely to see you split up than if you
were married i think it's the difference
between about 7 years and 13 years seven
years if you're cohabiting is the
average expectancy of a relationship 13
if you're married uh both of which are
obviously too low and again that brings
in the same thing that it's a bad
outcome for the kids
um various other things which people are
trying to destigmatize the obvious one
at the moment is obesity
uh we're told that that
that it's wrong to
to uh
stigmatize people who have fact to body
shame them to fat shame them and so on
and yet
perhaps that is one of the reasons why
we have such an obesity epidemic because
if you remove remove stigma
these things suddenly become normal and
and someone who is overweight
might well think that their body weight
is a normal weight because so many other
people have it and it's nothing to be
ashamed of but it's something to be
ashamed of because it will kill them
and because it's bad for society
well but rod where does that leave you
then because of the things that you've
mentioned you say you're divorcee you've
cohabited as well what are you knowingly
being stigmatized and okay without or
you think that you should be more
stigmatized or how do you how do you
reconcile that well
i i first started looking at uh
the effect of divorce
and single parent of single parenthood
is absolutely catastrophic for children
uh i mean in in in so many ways and i
haven't seen a single study which
disputes this it's absolutely
catastrophic for children
um
and i first started looking at the
figures and the effects and so on um
as i got divorced so in a way you know
it was it was provoked by my own
circumstances and i thought god you know
that this isn't the right thing to do
this really
wasn't the right thing to do um
either one shouldn't have got married in
the first place and had children or or
one shouldn't have got divorced that
that the outcomes for other people
are very very bad similarly
similarly i have to tell you that you
know um i'm a bit overweight now but
nothing like i was in
2014
when my children were what were they 14
and 16
and i had an argument with my youngest
son
uh you ended up telling me to
shut up you fat lady [ __ ]
exactly
were the words he
said and i thought god is that how he
sees me
uh and over the course of the next year
i lost four stone uh by
doing 10 miles a day walking
stigma works you know being called fatty
it works well actually it also removes
the other crucial thing with obesity is
that in a sense if you destigmatize it
you remove from the individual their own
personal responsibility for how they are
and obesity isn't something which is
visited upon someone by an outside agent
agency it's not the consequence of
poverty that's a ludicrous assertion
it's it's
possibly some of it's slightly tied in
with time poverty but i doubt that very
much
it's not the consequence of
big multinational companies being evil
and feeding people horrible food it's a
consequence of eating too much and not
getting enough exercise and that is down
to the individual
well actually rod let's talk about just
my final question of what kind of stigma
works you you use you
quote your son's very strong words then
in your column you'd call obese people
sweating wheezing gargantuan lard
buckets do you think that kind of
language that kind of stigma works or
more gentler kind of judgments it's
probably more gentler
you know
i i do remember um
uh
talking to
uh people who were my nieces they were
my nieces and they were
15 16 years old
and uh we were out in the street and
they saw a girl who was 15 women 16 to
17 years old walking past with a pram
and they said oh
single parent
and i thought well thank god for that
there is no aspiration on their part to
become a single parent
it's that it's it's just that innate
thing i don't want to do that because i
don't think it's good
you know and that's something
which stigma can inculcate rather than
having the government tell you you know
uh that's something that stigma can do
just
just make you sink before you go down a
path which
excuse me
which which will be injurious to you and
injurious to society
well rod thanks so much
sorry if i want you over
or
or are you all still
full of a
verve to send the students out whoring
well as a member of the millennial
generation i don't think you can
fully win me over but we have run out of
time but we'll have to continue this
conversation another time rod thanks for
joining us tv bye
thank you for watching spectator tv
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you